[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
i'm pleased to take part in this
outstanding event and welcome all
participants of the ftth conference
to my deep regret i cannot participate
personally due to the hostile inhuman
and brutal russian invasion of my
country
before this terrible war
uk telecom at the leading and one of the
largest fixed telco in ukraine was fully
focused on bridging the digital divide
in our country
it was completely in line with our
president vladimir zelansky target
to make ukraine one of the world's
leading digital democracies during just
two and a half years
before the war our company
has successfully implemented several
large-scale fiber rollout projects
the key ones among them are gpon swap
projects
that are targeted to a legacy copper
infrastructure replacement
as a result our customers
have gained a new internet experience
while ultra-fast fiber connections
the second fundamental type of the
projects
are so called greenfield
ones that are devoted to g pawn rollout
where the fixed internet coverage wasn't
available at all
we expanded the geography of ftth
connectivity in all the regions of
ukraine
every year we build thousands of
kilometers of fiber optic lines and
bring connectivity to the millions of
ukrainians
in 2021
alone
we have built the records thirteen
thousand and seven hundred kilometers of
fiber optic lines
significantly extended our network
we went deep to the rural ukraine where
they
extended fiber broadband connectivity to
more than 500 small towns and villages
we have connected to fiber broadband
3.7 000 social infrastructure facilities
including nearly 600 medical offices and
800 schools
owing to luke's telecom
last year
160 communities have been covered by our
fiber network as a result of all
mentioned
we end up totally with 4.5 million
people
covered by our recently deployed fiber
optic network this is all
what i as a ceo of crypto.com would have
be happy to talk with you on such
occasion
before the february 24th
2022
as you are all aware in the early
morning hours of february the 24th we
found ourselves in the new reality of a
full-scale brutal war of russia against
ukraine
from that time the world's
critical national infrastructure have
gained the real
meaning for ukrainian
talkers
then then we have been seeking for an
answer to the same questions over and
over again
do we still have connectivity
are we going to stay connected
and the firm yes to both of them is now
absolutely vital to our victory
the critical part of ukrainian national
telecom infrastructure our network is
relied upon by the ukrainian military
forces our state agencies banks
operating businesses and all ukrainians
in raw time staying connected is a basic
human need and we feel our
responsibility to ensure it is satisfied
our sensitivity
to the absence of connection has grown
multiple
at this very moment
thousands of our employees together with
our colleagues from other talkers are
standing as
one
to keep our people
businesses
and institutions connected each day
our fellows heroes set off the damaged
network segments and repair cables in
blasting craters
sometimes under sounds of explosions and
gunfire
over into their work the critical
infrastructure of telecom and its
backbone network is in operation with 85
of regional nodes functioning
our employees have shown an undeniable
commitment to this mission
and i share one out of dozens examples
one of our network engineers in mikalive
region on the south of the country
whose house was destroyed by shelling
while he and his family were hiding in
the bomb shelter and right after he saw
the devastation caused by the enemy to
his own home
the first thing he did was to get to the
network node and start the digital
generator as soon as possible to power
equipment and let people
to connect with emergency services and
their families
one of the important thing we found out
during this terrible war time with the
unity among all key telcos in ukraine
at 5 00 a.m on february 24th
all of us became
one
no space left for words competition
market share
there were eliminated from our daily
corporate vocabulary we are all united
by one mission to keep our military
forces
social institutions and people connected
whatever it takes
i also would like to say that we have
not entered
this war unprepared in 2014
russia annexed crimea and started its
hybrid warfare in the donbass region in
eastern part of ukraine
this day was an opportunity to gain war
time management experience when we were
forced to reconfigurate our network
operation having lost chunks of
infrastructure to the raw dawn so-called
authorities of crimea donetsk and
lugansk
made us stop our business operations and
services
in the occupied territories later our
stolen equipment were used by the
pirates
internet service providers such as
phoenix
lugacon crimea telecom
today we face and witness even more
brutal behavior
in the beginning of may
russian troops destroyed the backbone
line on the south of the country and
re-ruled part of the internet traffic in
the occupied harrison region to the
russian managed infrastructure i am
absolutely sure it was not possible
without involvement of russian operators
owing to ukrainian armed forces we
managed to restore
our connection in the region the state
special communication service of ukraine
is appealing to the international
telecommunication unit regarding this
incident russian mobile operators
including ross telecom playing up to the
aggressive military goals of their
government
they openly violate the rules and
standards for interconnection and
traffic routing established by the itu
and the european regulators moreover the
russian operators brutally ignore the
rules for using ipx number resources set
for global internet services
all involved russian operators roughly
challenge
the entire global and european telecom
community
having experienced this challenge and
its destructive power
we at hookster.com are absolutely
convinced that there can be only one
response to such brutal elections
to impose the tough functions against
russian operators and their adulation
from the global telecom community even
more i strongly believe
we need to complete embargo on
commercial and technological relations
with these companies in opposite to our
attitude to russians we deeply
appreciate technical and humanitarian
aid of our european partners orange
polska british telecom global east
grotel and the rest are helping us to
withstand the unprovoked and equal
military aggression
at the representative of ukrainian telco
community
i deeply appreciate all the actions
taken by the international colleagues
at the european union body of european
regulators for electronic communications
the european commission and all the
other committed organizations yet i am
one again calling to all the decision
makers and the honorary guests to
consider any actions possible to
suppress the ability
of the aggressor to work in our common
telecom space
i urge colleagues to consider the
international embargo on russian telcos
who are behaving
just as military pirates on ukrainian
territory we must heavily protect our
common information space and isolate
european telcas community from piracy
and propaganda content of russian
operators
at the end of my speech i'd like to
state
that we continue to fight for our land
our future our opportunity to share
european values and common
communications
thank you so much for listening me
and i do believe that one of the next
ftth conferences will take place in kiev
after inevitable victory of ukraine
[Music]
you